bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
au festival terres du son dernière
journée de cette édition 2010 est à nous
sommes au sud de tours au domaine de
candé amont et à 18h30 nous allons
pouvoir faire ça vous avez sans doute
évidemment reconnu l'un des tubes
d'imany merci d'être avec nous alors
laden enfin vous avez participé à ce
festival c'était en 2012 on le voit sur
cette affiche c'était précisément le 14
juillet qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
de revenir
c'était sur le planning ils m'ont dit de
revenir
je pense qu'il n'était pas déçu de ma
prestation en 2012 et jusqu'à quelqu'un
d'assez fidèle je pense que si vous
m'avez donné ma chance en 2012 et que
vous voulez que je revienne en 2017 as
c'est avec un grand plaisir que j'ai
beaucoup aimé cette ambiance champêtre
un parce qu'on est vraiment au coeur de
la nature ici oui et puis en plus j'aime
bien la mentalité du festival tout tout
tout tout ce militantisme autour de
l'écologie
eh bien il faut soutenir d'une manière
ou d'une autre cela va faire dix ans
l'année prochaine et que vous avez pris
vos premiers cours de chant à new york
parce que vous y aviez à cet instant ce
que vous imaginez qu'ils allaient vous
ouvrez les portes du succès en fait moi
ce que je dis toujours c'est que je
priais ma seule petite demande le soir
tout seul c'était je veux pouvoir faire
de la musique mais payer mes factures
avec et c'est tout quoi pouvoir vivre
avec la musique et j'ai eu beaucoup plus
donc non je l'imaginais pas tout ça je
voulais juste la musique ses cours de
chant vous aurez concilier avec votre
voix parce que semblerait-il elle vous
gêner un petit peu oui oui j'ai pris des
cours de chant il ya bien plus de dix
ans par ailleurs c'était à new york et
c'était plus vers 2004 2003 2004
ben ça m'a réconcilié vous savez les
complexes de ces patients sont emberas
vraiment mais j'ai fini par accepter que
c'était la voie que j'avais parfois je
peux pas l'écouter je veux pas vous
cacher et parfois ben j'y arrive c'est
irrégulier mais c'est vrai que c'est
plus l'acceptation moi même qui a fait
qui m'a aidé à accepter valeur est ce
qu'il ya une chanteuse qui vous a aidé à
aller encore plus loin dans
l'acceptation en a quelques-unes mais il
ya tracy chapman jelena simone qui ont
des voix un peu atypique tracy chapman
pendant ce temps je pensais même que
c'était un garçon quand j'étais
amine et c'était juste c'est important
quand on est jeunes d'avoir des exemples
des gens qui vous ressemble des modèles
des étoiles comme ça au loin qui vous
disent oui bah tu sais quoi et elles
sont un peu comme toi mais elles ont
réussi elle donc on se sent moins seul
et complexes finalement vous avez fait
un atout quels conseils donneriez-vous à
celles et ceux qui nous regardent et qui
ont un complexe quel qu'il soit
d'ailleurs
ben je leur dirai de commencer par
s'accepter tels qu'ils sont parce que
vous êtes comme vous êtes
moi j'aurais pas pu changer ma voix des
complexes qu'on ne peut pas payer des
choses qui sont intrinsèques à nous
mêmes qu'on peut pas changer le plus
simple finalement c'est de les accepter
et finalement d'inspirer les autres à
faire de même et après les possibilités
sont infinies et c'est génial
donc il faut commencer par se dire ben
je vous autant que les autres et arrêter
de se comparer votre dernier album can't
do fois à bord d'un en trame de fond à
l'amour un amour souvent tristes qui se
termine mal mais c'est une forme d'amour
qui vous touche
oui bien sûr qui me touche ce qui m'a
touché l'amour c'est pas simple ça de
vrai mais ça ne l'est pas cc c'est une
manière de j'aborde les choses de
manière très personnelle même si c'est
l'histoire des autres
pragmatique finalement vous préférez on
va dire au revoir toutes les formes
d'amour même celles qui peuvent détruire
de cet amour pour des futilités bien
souvent c'est à dire que des fois il
faut se poser la question pourquoi les
choses elle ne fonctionne pas par
moments on fait les mauvais choix et les
foi ont choisi de se battre pour des
choses qui n'ont pas de valeur et on met
son ego en avant au lieu de mettre
l'essentiel et on peut perdre une
histoire qui était à la base qui avait
toutes les chances d'être belle donc
c'est un constat moi je suis passé
certainement par là et dès fois
j'entends des histoires autour de moi et
souvent on se rend compte que en gach
des belles histoires pour rien alors
l'un des titres aussi dans cet album qui
s'appelle dans de bissau qui a été
repris remixé par le groupe électro
russe villa tové et cajas est ce que
c'est un genre musical que vous aimez
l'électro bikes pas forcément pas
forcément c'est pas ma chapelle en tout
cas
après c'est festif et et l'électro et
j'en écoute qu'on sortait quand je
sortais parce que je ne sors plus
maintenant et je comprends tout à fait
les faits après je pas une puriste
il ya des choses qui me dépasse
complètement mais je suis pas débile
le remix de dons bissau seuil de
philosophie grasset les ultra efficace
et le dire mais moi je pense dessus
il figure sur votre album aussi ah oui
effectivement ça s'appelle de musique
business donc disons nous ont connu
beaucoup de gens nous ont connus parce
par ce remix et donc c'était un moyen
aussi d'être identifiable porte d'entrée
pour découvrir votre univers mais ce qui
vous plaît surtout c'est la guitare et
le piano le piano pardon quelle
sensation vous procure en fait ces deux
instruments
en fait moi j'aime les instruments
acoustiques c'est vrai que j'ai une fan
de la guitare et du vieux dans celle en
fait j'adore le piano aussi mais la
guitare est violent 16 sont des
instruments kim kim tout ce que je
trouve honnête on peut pas se cacher en
plus je trouve que si j'avais deux
j'avais dû être un an seulement j'aurais
été un violoncelle je me sens proche de
cet instrument de manière organique quoi
vous mettez n'importe où dans n'importe
quel endroit avec une guitare vous allez
avoir des gens qui vont venir vers vous
n'est ce pas une guitare vous mettez à
chanter c'est un instrument extrêmement
extrêmement fédérateur universel vous
chanter uniquement en anglais pourquoi
vous banque vous vous boudez la langue
de molière
alors boudé c'est un grand mot quand
meme je sui entendez j'ai commencé à
écrire en anglais aux etats unis c'est
vrai c'était assez logique pour moi j'ai
appris je suis une autodidacte dont j'ai
appris à chanter tout seul et à écrire
surtout des chansons tout seul j'ai
appris là-bas en écoutant les artistes
comme tracy chapman
je voulais voir comment il avait fait
pour écrire une chanson et j'essaie de
les suivre
et puis j'avais tout de suite des envies
de carrière internationale et je me suis
dit on chante en français ça va être
compliqué il n'y a pas beaucoup de
chanteurs français qui qui ont réussi à
avoir une carrière internationale je me
dis il vaut mieux commencer par
l'anglais et l'anglais c'est une langue
très très facile beaucoup plus facile
c'est très très difficile d'écrire en
français sait pas c'est pas apporté tout
le monde je sais pas si c'est à ma
portée quand je chante en français il
est généralement je chante les chansons
des autres déjà réussi pour autant vous
n'oubliez pas vos racines puisque vous
êtes d'origine comorienne
là bas alors on parle non seulement le
français mais aussi l'arabe langue que
l'on retrouve dans votre nom de scène
imany qu'est ce que ça signifie imany ça
signifie la fois oui en arabe et en
swahili et le comorien c'est un mélange
d'arabe et de swahili
donc les gens parlent plutôt le comorien
mais il ya beaucoup de sauts il y est
pas mal d'arabes aussi la foi et
l'espoir vous l'avez depuis toujours ou
vous avez appris à l'avoir crois que
j'ai appris à l'avoir avoir la foi c'est
c'est pas toujours facile dans les temps
surtout dans les cantons dans lesquels
on vit mais c'est justement c'est
justement beau de pouvoir la trouver
dans un contexte compliqué j'ai dû la
prendre au bout d'un mois je serai aux
états unis j'étais une française bien
comment dire bien rond sont qui se
plaignait tout le temps et voilà et j'ai
rencontré des gens qui m'ont expliqué
que non non tu as de la vie elle est
passible est elle pas si moche pardon et
il faut il faut pouvoir trouver le
positif dans ce quota il faut en faire
vous faire avec ce que tu as j'ai appris
que la fois c'est ça aussi puis à une
phrase de edmond ressent que j'adore et
qui m'aide beaucoup c'est une phrase qui
dit c'est il est beau c'est dans
l'obscurité qu'il est beau de croire en
la lumière et la fois c'est ça pour moi
alors cette fois vous la transmettre
aussi auprès des personnes atteintes de
l'endométriose incite une maladie
gynécologique à vous êtes devenue
l'ambassadrice de l'association and mind
pourquoi vous êtes engagés dans cette
cause parce que j'estime que c'est une
véritable injustice faite aux femmes
c'est une maladie qui touche 22 à une à
deux femmes sur dix pardon en france a
fait à peu près 4 millions de femmes qui
s'ouvre tous les mois au moment de leurs
règles c'est une maladie qui était à
trouver en découvertes en 1850 et pour
autant d'un 2017 ya pas de cure il n'y a
pas de moyen de il n'y a pas de moyens
de dépistage
on ne sait pas comment on la trappe on
peut soigner des symptômes mais pas la
maladie c'est la première cause
d'infertilité
c'est des millions et des millions
d'euros en absentéisme dans le travail
et c'est je me suis posé la question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on envisage la
santé des femmes
on laisse 4 millions de femmes en france
180 millions dans le monde
souffrir comme ça tous les mois on
considère que souffrir tous les mois
c'est normal
voilà pourquoi je me suis engagé parce
que c'est un c'est injuste vous touche
d'autant plus parce que vous êtes maman
aussi depuis quelques temps oui je suis
maman depuis pas très longtemps ça fait
il a vingt mois malgré mon fils je suis
atteinte moi même de cette maladie mais
je le dis à chaque fois je pense que si
on m'avait acceptée a expliqué la
maladie dans les mêmes termes et j'avais
pas été atteinte je pense que je me
serais défendu quand même j'aurais
défendu la cause quand même le fait que
ce soit atteinte c'est encore plus
légitime on va dire mais ça me touche
parce que j'ai envie que l'âge et si les
choses bougent bougeront pas pour moi
c'est trop tard mais bouderont pour la
génération suivante et les bouches des
choses bougent énormément il ya des
campagnes qui se font il ya maintenant
et des gamines qui vont voir des
médecins à 16 17 ans au lieu d'attendre
les 10 ans de diagnostic qui avait avant
les choses bougent il ya encore des
choses à faire que vous sentez justement
de votre notoriété vous aide pour mettre
en place des projets pour défendre cette
cause
tout à fait mais je pense que mais c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait la notoriété ça
sert vraiment strictement à rien comme
ça c'est même quelque chose que j'ai eu
du mal à vivre au départ j'avais
l'impression de con je ne m'apparait
n'appartenait plus à moi même si vous
voulez quand les on vous arrête et
évidement des photos et des autographes
et est que l'anonymat dont vous puissiez
enfin presque sans vous en apercevoir
vous l'avez perdue la notoriété c'est
plus un handicap qu'autre chose mais si
vous l'utilisez pour l'autre pour une
cause pour eau produite et à ce
moment-là tout ça ça a du sens et c'est
pour ça que je le fais parce que grâce à
ma notoriété je peux aller discuter avec
vous devant plein de gens et et rendre
la maladie encore plus connus et plus
les gens se manifesteront et feront en
sorte que ces choses bougent et plus
j'aurais l'impression que ma notoriété
aura servi à quelque chose
merci il manie une toute dernière
question quels sont vos prochains
projets pour les semaines à venir avant
les semaines à venir j'ai encore un bon
mois de festival
jusqu'au 6 août et après je pars en
vacances un mois ça ne m'est pas arrivé
depuis le premier album de chez propos
aux comores je pars aux comores vous
savez tout ouais j'aurais peut-être pas
du lierre mais je pars en vacances et
vous partez là bas vous vous sentez
comme à la maison vous vous perdez on va
dire cette notoriété ou là bas aussi on
vient sans cesse discute avec vous
échangez où on préfère vous laisser en
vacances parce qu'on sait que vous vous
l'êtes
je vais vous faire une confession je ne
suis pas retournée aux comores depuis le
succès donc là d'un fonctions je suis
allée g t et nadia comme comme n'importe
quel gamine qui allait avoir ses parents
comment es tu es là je sais pas donc je
vais essayer de me faire le plus discret
possible juste parce que j'y vais en
famille avec mon mari qui n'est jamais
allée qui connaît pas les comores et mon
bébé et que j'y vais vraiment pour me
reposer
si je rencontre des gens qui ont envie
de témoigner
l'amour qu'ils ont pour moi je serais
contente mais je j'y vais vraiment
discrètement j'y vais pas pour plein de
beaux souvenirs vécus ici notamment
centre val de loire avec ce festival
terres du son ce sera donc ce soir à
partir de 18h30 merci d'avoir été avec
nous on va se retrouver un peu plus tard
évidemment sur facebook france 3 centre
val de loire
on sera en compagnie de l'artiste mom un
autre univers musical aussi mais que
vous appréciez on l'a compris d'une
manière ou d'une autre un merci vanni a
très vite